I haven't seen a couple weeks having
been I've been alright it's been a tough
year I lost they I lost a good friend oh
you did well back yeah and it was just
it just came out of the blue you know he
went for a physical and the doctor found
a terminal illness and they gave him
three months to live you know it's a
shock to all of us we were devastated
because like I said it came out of
nowhere and you know we threw him a
party and I think that's the thing to do
is to have a party for somebody while
they're alive and you know celebrate
their life what we did we toast to them
we danced with him even we told stories
about him and basically we said goodbye
to him you know and that three months
came and went quicker than any of us had
expected and he was still alive was
still alive three months four months
five months still alive but now he's
embarrassed that he's still alive and
rightfully so because we threw a really
nice party for him and it costs a lot of
money because we thought the three-month
thang yeah right and then five months to
like six months seven months eight
months oh my god and then December 17th
2018 he was still like shame he's
ashamed that he's still alive feels
awkward about ah because I did I put a
lot of money into that party I mean I
used to love this guy yeah used to love
him you used to love them now and then I
had my I had a birthday party which I
had invited him him to a long time ago
cuz I didn't think he'd be around right
and he shows up and he's like eating the
good organic stuff you know he's having
a lot of cake right and it would be
taking more than his share yes yeah and
it was a small party - I didn't have a
lot to put into it cuz I spent all my
money in his party you know so now I'm
suffering right and he's seven i well I
saw him even smile he's like smiling off
to the side he's having a good time
inside off you know anyway
14 months later he died thankfully
thankfully he died yeah he did die he
did die but it had nothing to do with
the disease he was actually hit by a car
was hit by a car yes I was driving the
car
[Laughter]
what are you why do people applaud that
there was a dad and the doctors gave him
four months to live
we're here we go here we go here we go
yeah